on a justement été demandé à des
habitants de Saint-Quentin s'il serait
prêt eux-mêmes à financer des projets de
cette manière je vous propose d'écouter
leurs réponses
parce que les banques c'est pas fiable
on paye trop de taxes pour eux et ça
vaut pas le coup j'ai déjà prêté
d'argent des amis et c'est super bien
quand il s'agit de personnes oui
pourquoi pas ou déjà on a tout chacun à
ces projets à gérer après oui
effectivement sur des petits projets
pourquoi pas mais sur le principe chacun
gère déjà ses projets et après on verra
quoi pourquoi pas si j'ai les moyens de
le faire évidemment c'est l'entraide
c'est important
il y a des organismes pour ça quoi j'ai
passé par là et puis je sais ce que
c'est
et puis j'ai jamais besoin de
particulier aujourd'hui on a des des
prêts qui sont avec des taux énorme et
c'est pas forcément évident de faire
front et si et si au niveau de la
population on peut s'entraider pourquoi
pas
alors on voit que les gens sont
finalement assez réceptifs à ce genre de
financement reste la question du
remboursement qui peut qui peut
finalement faire peur
la vraie vie lorsque vous empruntez un
ami ou quand un ami vous prête vous êtes
patient récupérer votre argent non plus
et en l'occurrence sur Allo merci on n'a
pas de solution miracle pour ça par
contre on crée comme un contexte qui est
radicalement différent c'est que quand
vous avez emprunté il y a des gens que
vous connaissez publicment si vous
remboursez pas vos amis votre famille
les Noël et les animations qui suivent
deviennent quand même très très
compliqué ce qui est incroyable sur les
plateformes de crowdfunding et c'est
pour ça que ça fonctionne c'est que ça
crée une pression sociale autour du du
créateur du porteur de projet beaucoup
plus fort que dans une banque dans une
banque vous déposez le bilan vous êtes
interdit bancaire un an vous devez rien
à personne puisque vous allez pas
rembourser là vous allez devoir
rencontrer les gens un par un en force
de vous et si vous les remboursez pas ça
venir très très compliqué tout le milieu
du crowdf en ligne dans le monde et
l'explosion du crowdfunding dans le
monde tient uniquement sur cette valeur
là qui est transparente empathie et
partage c'est ce que vous ressentez le
rendu
c'est vrai que pour l'anecdote moi je
pensais que c'était ma mère qui allait
me prêter le plus de toute façon on
aurait prêté et il se trouve que c'est
pas elle donc maman c'est un petit
message pour toi au passage mais Vincent
a raison c'était qu'il y a une pression
et en même temps il y a quand même c'est
une pression saine c'est à dire qu'on a
envie de réussir et donc finalement de
toute façon on sait qu'il faut
rembourser si on rembourse pas au-delà
du fait que les nouvelles sont
difficiles c'est aussi l'entreprise et
l'image de l'entreprise qui est pas
bonne donc de toute façon ça fait partie
du challenge et c'est aussi l'intérêt de
demander des sommes qui sont
raisonnables en cas de galère de pouvoir
rembourser peut-être un peu autrement
qu'avec la seule activité d'entreprise
alors juste un dernier point pour
conclure il y a un donc un autre site
friends clear qui proposait donc plus
pour des entrepreneurs individuels ou
des petites entreprises des dépress
solidaires de cette manière ils ont
finalement évolué ce n'est plus des
prêts à taux zéro il y a un taux de
rendement vous ça ne bougera pas
presque plus
ils ont une difficulté majeure avec les
tours rémunérés c'est que vous rentrez
dans le cadre du monopole bancaire et en
France aujourd'hui c'est un praticable
ils ont essayé d'or ils ont été très
courageux ils ont cette force et les
portes et ça va finir par payer parce
qu'on discute avec le gouvernement en ce
moment et des autorités de contrôle pour
changer cette règle mais très clairement
aujourd'hui le prêt rémunéré en France
sous cette forme est très compliqué et
le choix d'un prêt à taux zéro se place
dans une logique qui est radicalement
différente dans une plateforme vous
allez prêter de l'argent avec
rémunération c'est la rémunération qui
vous importe dans une sur une plateforme
où vous prêtez sans retour sur
investissement il y a que le retour sur
investissement émotionnel qui vous
importe donc on n'est pas du tout dans
le même cadre on pourrait très bien
imaginer un matin se lever nous cousins
se prêter de l'argent pour un les perso
entrepreneurial et le mardi se lever et
du coup prêté à une entreprise que vous
connaissez pas ou vous venez chercher du
rendement donc c'est pas des jeux qui
sont incompatibles c'est logique qui
sont juste différentes merci à tous les
trois merci merci à vous trois claire à
présent quelques infos en plus la
première concerne continentale à
Rambouillet cette menace de chômage
partiel sur une unité de production et
oui en 2008 déjà la moitié des effectifs
soit 382 emplois avaient été supprimés à
la rentrée prochaine le dégraissage va
continuer 50 à 80 personnes de l'atelier
devraient être mis au chômage partiel
selon la direction les salariés
concernés réalisent les fins de série
d'autoradio et de systèmes de navigation
le prix entreprise environnement lancé
ce lundi oui organisé tous les deux ans
il récompense les entreprises des
Yvelines et du Val-d'Oise qui ont engagé
des actions exemplaires de développement
durable parmi les organisateurs
l'association Yvelines environnement
mais aussi les chambres de commerce et
les conseillers conseils généraux
pardonés de départements les entreprises
peuvent concourir dans quatre catégories
nouveau procédés industriels au nouveau
produit action de sensibilisation
politique de management environnemental
et prévention au traitement on est
quitte coûte deux organisateurs
il s'adresse absolument à l'ensemble des
entreprises
et nous tenons beaucoup aussi à ce que
les PME puissent participer c'est
important parce qu'évidemment les grands
groupes ont peut-être plus de faciliter
pour se mettre au nord respecter les
règles du Grenelle et autres il y a déjà
une valorisation en interne de la
société puisque ils ont fait des efforts
ils ont fait des efforts pour leur
process et puis et puis vis-à-vis de
leur concurrents ou de leur fournisseurs
même c'est une image assez importante et
pour terminer cette chronique de l'écho
l'agenda quelques dates quelques dates à
retenir Versailles Club d'Affaires
organise mardi un petit déjeuner
d'information sur le thème les emplois
d'avenir pour les entreprises
rendez-vous à 8h30 à la Mission Locale
de Versailles et puis le 26 juin dans le
cadre des Rencontres de la Maison de
l'Entreprise vous pourrez assister à une
réunion d'information sur la création en
auto-entreprise pour comprendre le
régime et ses déclarations notamment
rendez-vous donc à la Maison de
l'Entreprise de Montigny cette fois et
puis pour finir un forum emploi
diversité aura lieu le 27 juin à plaisir
le but affiché casser les préjugés et
favoriser l'insertion des catégories
socioprofessionnelles victimes de
discrimination et de moments d'or
d'emploi peuvent donc se rendre dès 9h à
la Maison de l'Entreprise et de l'emploi
merci Claire pour la chronique de l'Echo
on vous retrouvera la semaine prochaine
aux mêmes heures rubrique à revoir aussi
en replay sur notre site internet
je vous donne quelques unes des
informations que nous avons également
développées ce soir nous en parlions
hier de fortes pluies orageuses se sont
abattus en fin de journée dans le
département notamment sur 50 ans en
Yvelines il est tombé 50 mm d'eau ce
mercredi dans le département c'est
l'équivalent des précipitations de tout
un mois de juin un événement remarquable
mais pas exceptionnel pour autant on
écoute l'un des prévisionnistes de Météo
France à Trappes Philippe misray le
record de précipitation à Trappes il
date de juillet 2001 avec 90 mm en 24
heures donc là on a on a si vous voulez
sur trappes on a on a eu une trentaine
de millimètres en 24 heures donc c'est
pas mal mais on est loin des records et
puis la fête de la musique 2013 ce sera
demain 21 juin quelques fois le samedi
également à travers toute la France la
programmation sur les sites Internet qui
s'affichent en ce qui concerne
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines mais aussi
Versailles et puis aussi le reste de la
France elle se rendait vous faites ça
32e édition initiée par le ministère de
la culture française c'est aujourd'hui
une centaine de pays qui participent il
encourage les musiciens amateur se
produire bénévolement dans les rues et
les espaces publics grâce à
l'organisation de nombreux concerts
gratuits à l'occasion aussi de découvrir
de nouveaux genres musicaux d'élargir
ses horizons merci de nous avoir suivis
vendredi samedi dimanche Antoni Reich
pour le 7 8 weekends et un résumé
complet de l'actualité de la semaine
ainsi qu'un entretien avec le rappeur
yvelin ASCO dont le nouveau clip vient
de sortir il a pour vedette Medhi
vainqueur de l'émission de télé-réalité
La Belle et ses princes si vous êtes
amateurs lui aussi d'ailleurs sera sur
ce plateau je vous retrouve lundi pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 consacré à
l'actualité nouvelle semaine d'actualité
d'information locale excellent weekend à
lundi